OK, I've been happily gabbing away with Harold Wilshinsky for maybe 15 minutes when he suddenly came out with this warning.
好的，我和哈罗德·威尔辛斯基愉快地闲聊了大概15分钟，他突然冒出了这句警告。
You start an insurance man talking, you're out of luck.
你只要让一个保险从业者打开话匣子，你就倒霉了。
This seemed to refer to a body of folk wisdom about the ways of insurance men that I had never heard of, but I kept my mouth shut about that because Harold is the kind of person I don't run into much. Harold is a dapper, cufflinks-wearing, 79-year-old and he gives advice to people for a living-- insurance advice, estate planning advice.
这似乎是指某种我从未听说过的关于保险从业者行事风格的民间智慧，但我对此保持沉默，因为哈罗德是我不常遇到的人。哈罗德是一位穿着考究、戴着袖扣的79岁老人，他靠给人提供建议为生——保险建议、遗产规划建议。
And I had asked him to come into the studio to tell the story of this piece of advice that he gave over 15 years ago to his own daughter and son-in-law. Back then, they'd invested all their money with this guy who ran this great hedge fund. And it was all their money, which Harold was not happy with. He says that violates one of the basic rules of investment.
我请他到演播室来，讲讲他15年前给他女儿和女婿的那条建议背后的故事。当时，他们把所有的钱都投给了一个运营着一家优秀对冲基金的家伙。那是他们的全部积蓄，哈罗德对此很不高兴。他说这违反了投资的基本原则之一。
Diversification. And I said I don't care how good this guy is. I don't care if he's God himself. You just don't put all your money with one person. I mean, 20, 25% of your money, fine, but how do you put all your-- all with someone named Madoff?
分散投资。我说我不在乎那家伙有多厉害。我不在乎他是不是上帝本人。你就是不能把所有钱都放在一个人手里。我的意思是，拿出20%到25%的钱还可以，但你怎么能把你所有的钱都交给一个叫麦道夫的人呢？
Madoff, of course, was Bernie Madoff, who just this week pleaded guilty to 11 felony charges and went to jail for what prosecutors say was a $65 billion-- that's billion with a B-- Ponzi scheme. But back in 1993 or so when all this happened--
当然，麦道夫就是伯尼·麦道夫，就在本周，他承认了11项重罪并入狱，检察官称这是一场650亿美元——注意，是B开头的十亿——的庞氏骗局。但在1993年左右，当这一切发生时——
I didn't know Madoff from a hole in the wall.
我对麦道夫一无所知。
The son-in-law, whose name is Merrill, had given to Madoff his entire pension fund. It was maybe half a million dollars. And he gave Madoff this money because his father and two of his brothers had those given everything they had to Madoff. Like all of Madoff's clients, on paper they were doing great, earning 15, 20% on their money each and every year-- a huge rate of return. But when Harold asked, how does he get that great return, Merrill had no idea. None of Madoff's clients did. Madoff wouldn't tell them how he made the money. It was proprietary.
女婿梅里尔把他的全部养老金都交给了麦道夫。那大概有50万美元。他把钱交给麦道夫是因为他的父亲和两个兄弟也都把所有的钱交给了麦道夫。像麦道夫所有的客户一样，从账面上看，他们做得很好，每年都能获得15%到20%的收益——这是一笔巨大的回报率。但当哈罗德问他是如何获得如此高回报时，梅里尔根本不知道。麦道夫的客户没人知道。麦道夫拒绝告诉他们他是如何赚钱的。这是商业机密。
And did it seem suspicious to you?
这对你来说看起来可疑吗？
No. No. I'd love to be able to answer you and say oh yeah, I knew. I had it figured. Because I would be one of the few geniuses in that field. No.
没有。没有。我倒希望我能回答说，哦，是的，我早就看穿了。因为那样我就是那个领域里为数不多的天才了。不，并没有。
He just thought that it was bad throw all your money into one hedge fund. And he made this very, very clear-- abundantly clear-- to his daughter Pam and to Merril.
他只是认为把所有钱都投进一家对冲基金是不对的。他非常、非常清楚地——极其明确地——向他的女儿帕姆和女婿梅里尔表达了这一点。
And I'm not exactly shy about stating my beliefs on things.
而且我在表达自己的信仰方面从来不含糊。
Yes. Yes, he loves to give advice, especially to me.
是的。是的，他喜欢提建议，尤其是对我。
This is Pam, and with her, Merrill.
这是帕姆，还有她身边的梅里尔。
Child rearing, advice on relationships, marital.
育儿建议，人际关系建议，婚姻建议。
And he heard that all of that money was in one fund and he always believed in diversification.
他听说所有的钱都在一家基金里，而他一直坚信分散投资。
And he was very emotional. He felt very strongly that we were making a huge mistake and we needed to fix it right away. And he made me so nervous that then, after he left, my husband and I had an entire discussion, let's say. And I said, you'd better get your money out of there tomorrow. I don't care about what your brothers say, because I figured they would be upset, which they were.
他当时非常激动。他强烈地感到我们犯了一个大错，必须立即改正。他让我感到非常紧张，以至于他走后，我和我丈夫进行了彻底的讨论，我们可以这么说。我说，你最好明天就把钱拿出来。我不管你兄弟们怎么说，因为我猜他们会不高兴的，事实也确实如此。
She and Merrill were so frantic that Merrill didn't just diversify like Harold was suggesting. He pulled all their money out of Madoff's hedge fund.
她和梅里尔非常恐慌，以至于梅里尔不仅没有像哈罗德建议的那样分散投资，而是直接把他们所有的钱都从麦道夫的对冲基金里撤了出来。
Her father got me so nervous.
她父亲把我搞得太紧张了。
I would've bit your head off if you would've left in anything.
如果你当初留下一点钱，我会气疯的。
And then something kind of unfortunate happened to them. For the next 16 years, Merrill had to watch his brothers and his father make a fortune with Madoff. Their money doubled every three or four years until they had millions. And this wasn't just on paper. Merrill's dad was retired and his account was set up to send him a check every month to live off of. He felt so strongly about Madoff that on his deathbed, he actually urged Merrill to please, please, just one thing, please go back to Madoff. And so for sixteen years, Harold's advice to leave Madoff really seemed like the worst advice Merrill had ever been given.
然后发生了一件对他们来说有点不幸的事。接下来的16年里，梅里尔不得不眼睁睁地看着他的兄弟们和父亲通过麦道夫发了横财。他们的钱每三四年就翻一番，直到他们拥有了数百万美元。这不仅仅是账面上的。梅里尔的父亲退休了，他的账户设置成每月给他寄支票以供生活。他对麦道夫的信任如此之深，以至于在临终前，他还恳求梅里尔一定要，拜托，只有这一件事，一定要回到麦道夫那里。所以在这16年里，哈罗德离开麦道夫的建议看起来真是梅里尔收到过的最糟糕的建议。
I was very upset with him for 16 years.
那16年我对他非常不满。
He was very angry. And then every so often, he would rant and rave. "Your big mouth stupid father. Cost me all this money. Why didn't he keep his big mouth--" He would never say a word to my father. I would hear about my stupid father.
他非常生气。每隔一段时间，他就会大吼大叫。“你那嘴碎的蠢父亲。让我损失了这么多钱。为什么他不闭上他的大嘴——”他从来不会对我父亲说一个字。我只听到他抱怨我那愚蠢的父亲。
And my daughter never missed an opportunity. God bless her. To let me know about-- she was like his spokesperson. Merrill thinks, Merrill doesn't-- [LAUGHS]
而且我女儿从来没放过任何机会。上帝保佑她。让我知道——她就像他的代言人。梅里尔觉得，梅里尔不——[笑]
And what would she say to you?
她会对你说些什么呢？
You know, I don't think Merrill will ever get over what you did when you told him to take his money out.
你知道，我觉得梅里尔永远不会忘记当你告诉他把钱取出来时所做的事。
I would say to him, you're such a know it all. Why didn't you keep your mouth shut if you didn't know about this Madoff?
我会对他说，你真是个自以为是的人。如果你对这个麦道夫一无所知，为什么不闭上你的嘴？
I said, Pam, I didn't tell him to take his money out. I told him he should diversify. She didn't want to know.
我说，帕姆，我没告诉他要把钱全取出来。我告诉他应该分散投资。她根本不想听。
And let me ask you, did you, at some point, start to regret that advice?
让我问问你，你有在某个时刻开始后悔那个建议吗？
That's an excellent question. No. That's amazing, now that you mention it. No.
这是一个很好的问题。没有。真令人惊讶，现在你提到了，我才发现。没有。
And then finally, after 16 years of family strife about this-- 16 years on the wrong side of history-- Harold found himself vindicated. This fall, Madoff was arrested. The truth came out about his con.
最终，在经历了16年的家庭纷争之后——在历史的错误一边站了16年——哈罗德终于证明了自己的正确。今年秋天，麦道夫被捕了。关于他骗局的真相浮出水面。
The news broke, if I'm not mistaken, on a Thursday. And Friday night, I get a call from Merrill. Now, Merrill seldom calls me unless he had something specific. And he is just waxing poetic. My God, you'd think I represented the second coming. All these geniuses didn't have this figured. You knew and you had it figured and you understood this and-- And I said, Merrill, all I said was diversify.
如果我没记错的话，新闻是在周四爆出的。周五晚上，我接到了梅里尔的电话。梅里尔很少给我打电话，除非有什么特别的事。他当时简直是在歌功颂德。天哪，你以为我是救世主再世。所有那些天才都没看出来。你竟然知道，你竟然看穿了，你竟然理解了——我说，梅里尔，我当时只说了分散投资。
The oldest trick in the book.
最古老的把戏。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And he didn't want to know. He I thought that I was an absolute genius and I knew. Finally, I said, Merrill, my God, the last time someone spoke to me this way was my late mother.
是啊，是啊，是啊。他根本不想听。我以为我是个绝对的天才，我早就知道。最后我说，梅里尔，天哪，上一次有人这样跟我说话还是我已故的母亲。
Well, so then what happened when you finally saw your daughter again?
那么，当你终于再次见到你女儿时，发生了什么？
A word was never spoken and I didn't bring it up. If she wasn't saying it, I wasn't saying it. And that's the way it's been.
一个字都没提，我也没提起。如果她不提，我就不提。事情就是这样。
it's nice to be 80 years old and to be able to say-- whether you say it or not-- I told you so. I'm the smart one. You're the idiot. I told you.
80岁了还能说出——不管你有没有说出口——“我早就告诉过你”的感觉真好。我是那个聪明人。你是那个傻瓜。我告诉过你。
Did he say that?
他说那话了吗？
No. No. No, he didn't say that.
没有。没有。没有，他没说。
You've never been tempted to say I told you so?
你从来没有想过要说“我早就告诉过你”吗？
Nope. Nope. Gee, that sounds pretty good, you know? I'm impressed with myself now. No, I didn't. It's just a matter of dealing with people and especially your kids. You don't play gotcha.
没有。没有。天哪，那听起来一定很爽，你知道吗？我现在对自己印象深刻。不，我没说。这只是处理人际关系的问题，尤其是面对你的孩子。你不能玩那种“抓住了吧”的游戏。
Pam says that there's another reason that her dad never said I told you so. And that's that they know people who lost all their savings to Bernie Madoff. Two of Merrill's brothers took huge hits. Merrill's stepmom lost her retirement money. In the face of that, Pam and Merrill don't much feel like celebrating. And her dad doesn't feel like gloating.
帕姆说她父亲从不说“我早就告诉过你”还有另一个原因。那就是他们认识一些把所有积蓄都输给伯尼·麦道夫的人。梅里尔的两个兄弟遭受了巨大打击。梅里尔的继母失去了养老金。面对这些，帕姆和梅里尔没心情庆祝。而她的父亲也没心思幸灾乐祸。
Sometimes it's hard to feel good about being on the right side of history because you know so many people who are on the wrong side, which brings us to today's radio program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, The Wrong Side of History. We have four stories of people who find themselves on the losing side of big historical trends. In Act One, NPR economics correspondent Adam Davidson is back on our show and he is worried that one of his own relatives-- somebody he's close to-- is trying to defy the world economy. Act Two, we have a story of a man cast out by a political campaign. Act Three, some advice for everybody living in the 14th century. Act Four, Alex Kotlowitz on a man who is going down in history as something everybody who knows him says he wasn't for most of his life. Stay with us.
有时候，站在历史正确的一边很难感到高兴，因为你知道太多人站在了错误的一边，这让我们回到了今天的广播节目。从芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是《历史的错误一边》。我们有四个关于人们发现自己处于重大历史潮流失败一边的故事。在第一幕中，NPR经济记者亚当·戴维森回到我们的节目，他担心他的一个亲戚——他关系很近的人——正在试图挑战全球经济。第二幕，我们有一个关于一个人被政治竞选拒之门外的故事。第三幕，给所有生活在14世纪的人的一些建议。第四幕，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨讲述了一个男人在历史上被定义为所有认识他的人都说他大半辈子都不是那种人。请继续收听。
Act One, Hey Mister DJ. And we're joined right now by one of our regular contributors, Planet Money correspondent, NPR economics correspondent, Adam Davidson. And Adam, you are here today on a mission.
第一幕，嘿，DJ先生。现在我们的常驻贡献者、Planet Money通讯员、NPR经济通讯员亚当·戴维森加入我们。亚当，你今天带着一个任务来到这里。
I am on a mission. And that mission is to save my cousin DJ's life-- to make his life better.
我确实带着任务。那个任务是拯救我表弟DJ的生活——让他的生活变得更好。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, and I want to say I love DJ. He's like my awesome little brother. He's really smart. He's really, really funny. And I feel like he has made a horrible decision. He has literally made the decision that puts him on the wrong side of our economy.
是的，我想说我爱DJ。他就像我了不起的小弟弟。他真的很聪明。他真的很幽默。我觉得他做出了一个可怕的决定。他实际上做出了一个让他处于我们经济错误一边的决定。
So he's in the wrong side of the economy, he is on the wrong side of history, it in what way?
所以他处于经济的错误一边，历史的错误一边，在什么方面？
He dropped out of college. He did the one thing-- let me explain why I get so upset about this. And I am. I'm feeling myself angry at DJ right now while we're talking. So I am international business and economics correspondent for NPR, which basically means I spend much of my time talking to leading experts, studying the role of the US in the global economy. And there is one thing I've learned with absolute certainty, which is that the competitive advantage of the United States and our citizens, the way we will succeed in this global economy going forward, is through skills, education, knowledge. In other words, stay in school. Get a college degree. And you'll be in a much better position.
他从大学退学了。他做了那一件事——让我解释一下我为什么对此如此愤怒。因为我确实很生气。我现在和DJ说话时就感到很生气。我是NPR的国际商业和经济通讯员，这意味着我大部分时间都在与顶尖专家交谈，研究美国在全球经济中的作用。有一件事我非常确定，那就是美国的竞争力以及我们公民的竞争力，我们未来在全球经济中取得成功的方式，是通过技能、教育和知识。换句话说，留在学校。拿到大学学位。你会处于更好的位置。
In the global economy.
在全球经济中。
In the global economy. And if you drop out of college, then you have, basically, consciously decided to just not partake in the economic growth and possibilities of the coming decades. And it's going to get worse and worse and worse, that 10 years from now and then 30 years from now and 40 years from now, you will make less money, you have less opportunity.
在全球经济中。如果你从大学退学，那么你基本上就是有意识地决定不参与未来几十年的经济增长和可能性。情况会变得越来越糟，10年后，30年后，40年后，你赚的钱会更少，你的机会也会更少。
OK, and so as I understand it, you've tried to convince DJ of this, you have been completely unsuccessful. And so you have now enlisted some help.
好吧，据我所知，你试着说服DJ接受这一点，但完全失败了。所以你现在寻求了一些帮助。
Yes, I have a friend, Pietra Rivoli. She's a professor of economics at Georgetown University. So I thought, well, DJ won't listen to me. Maybe he will listen to a qualified expert-- a professor of economics.
是的，我有一个朋友，皮特拉·里沃利。她是乔治城大学的经济学教授。我想，好吧，DJ不听我的。也许他会听一位合格的专家——一位经济学教授的话。
All right, so I'm going to bow out now and you're going to speak to both of them. They are both on the line. Good luck.
好的，那么我现在退出了，你们三个人谈吧。他们都在线上。祝你们好运。
DJ, let's start with you. What are you, 25? How old?
DJ，我们从你开始吧。你多大了，25岁？对吧？
Yeah, getting up there.
是的，快到了。
You graduated high school and then you went to Quinsigamond Community College right there in Worcester, right?
你高中毕业后去了伍斯特的奎西加蒙德社区学院，对吧？
That's right.
没错。
And what happened then?
然后发生了什么？
I went for about two weeks and decided it was time to tell my father that I'd never wanted to go in the first place and I don't want to be here now, so I'm going to have to drop out.
我去了大约两周，决定是时候告诉父亲我根本不想去，现在也不想待在那里，所以我必须退学。
Now you told me that you actually wished you had dropped out earlier in your life?
你告诉我你其实希望自己早点退学？
Yeah, if I had more time to work and make money then, I would rather have done that.
是的，如果那时我有更多时间工作赚钱，我宁愿那样做。
You mean not gone to high school and made money from 14 or 15?
你是说没有上高中，从14或15岁就开始赚钱？
Yeah, but still, the high school experience was definitely worth it, but--
是的，不过高中经历绝对值得，但是——
Because you were a big football star and all the girls loved you.
因为你是橄榄球明星，所有的女孩都喜欢你。
Yeah, that's part of it.
是的，那也是一部分原因。
What do you think your life is going to be like as a guy with a high school degree but no advanced education?
你觉得一个只有高中学历、没有高等教育的男人，生活会是什么样？
I'm going to work a hands-on construction job for the rest of my life and have sore body parts every day.
我这辈子都要做体力建筑工作，每天身体都会酸痛。
What are you doing now?
你现在做什么？
I work for Henkels &  McCoy. We do telecommunications. It's pretty much outside construction.
我为亨克尔斯麦考伊公司工作。我们做电信相关业务。这基本上是户外建筑工作。
I'd call you a ditch digger.
我会叫你挖沟工。
Yeah, I dig ditches by hand.
是的，我用手挖沟。
Now before that, you were a bodyguard or a bouncer at a strip club?
在此之前，你是脱衣舞俱乐部的保镖或保安？
Yeah, we don't have to go into details, but yes, I did a little of that.
是的，我们不必深究细节，但没错，我做过一段时间。
What is it, Crazy Girls? What's the name?
是什么俱乐部，疯狂女孩？名字叫什么？
No, it's Centerfold's.
不，是中心折页俱乐部。
Centerfold's, right. And what you think? When you look at our uncles, for example, they didn't go to college and they've done pretty well, right?
中心折页俱乐部，对。你是怎么想的？当你看着我们的叔叔们，比如，他们没上过大学，但他们做得很好，对吧？
Kenny's a truck driver. And Phil is a connoisseur.
肯尼是个卡车司机。菲尔是个美食家。
A connoisseur.
美食家。
If you knew him, that would be really funny.
如果你认识他，那会非常有趣。
That's very funny. I'm just saying, from where you're sitting if you looked around our family-- and our grandfather, Pepe. He didn't go to college. He had a good life. He owned his own house, he had a car, he had a vacation home, or at least a vacation--
那很有趣。我只是说，从你现在的角度看，如果你环顾我们的家族——还有我们的爷爷，佩佩。他没上过大学。他过得很好。他有自己的房子，有车，有度假屋，或者至少是一个度假——
Trailer.
拖车。
Trailer, yeah. And he was a truck dispatcher. But here's what I want to say to you. I think that you don't understand that the world has changed from the world that our uncles and grandparents lived in and that your future will be much worse if you don't go to college. And I want Pietra to tell me if I'm right.
拖车，是啊。他是个卡车调度员。但我想要告诉你的是，我觉得你不明白世界已经从我们叔叔和祖辈生活的世界改变了，如果你不去上大学，你的未来会糟糕得多。我想让皮特拉告诉我我说得对不对。
You know, Adam, I'm not sure you are after I've listened to DJ and hear a little about all he's done in his 25 years. A lot of people, historically, didn't go to college, worked in low-skill manufacturing jobs. And in the global economy today, those are exactly the jobs that have disappeared, or some people say moved, to China and Mexico and so forth. So if you worked in one of those old textile factories in Massachusetts and the textile factory closed, then you're kind of out of luck without a college degree.
你知道，亚当，听了DJ的话，了解了他25年来所做的一切后，我不太确定你是对的。历史上很多人没上过大学，从事低技能制造业工作。在全球经济中，这些正是已经消失，或者有些人说搬迁到中国、墨西哥等地的岗位。所以如果你在马萨诸塞州的一家旧纺织厂工作，纺织厂倒闭了，那没有大学学位的你确实会很倒霉。
But if you listen to DJ's history, let's see, he was a bouncer at a strip club, he's putting up telecom equipment, he works on construction sites. These are all careers or jobs that we would say are-- well, t the technical term would be they're non-tradable. So in other words, that bouncer job is not moving to China. And, in fact, the strippers inside, their job's not moving to China either. And the work he's doing setting up telecom lines or what have you.
但如果你听听DJ的历史，你看，他做过脱衣舞俱乐部的保安，他在安装电信设备，他在建筑工地工作。这些都是我们可以称之为——技术术语是不可贸易的岗位。换句话说，那个保安工作不会搬到中国。事实上，里面的脱衣舞女，她们的工作也不会搬到中国。还有他设置电信线路所做的工作等等。
Digging ditches.
挖沟。
That can't move. The ditch digging can't move. And if I listen to some of your family history, there's a lot of jobs in that history that aren't moving too. Truck drivers-- those aren't going to China, for example. These jobs aren't going to disappear. And it sounds like DJ's developing a number of those.
那不能搬走。挖沟没法搬走。如果我听听你们家族的一些历史，那段历史中有很多工作也不会搬走。卡车司机——他们不会去中国，例如。这些工作不会消失。听起来DJ正在培养很多这样的技能。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Well, I'm very frustrated because I thought--
好吧，我很沮丧，因为我以为——
In your face, Adam.
亚当，打脸了吧。
I thought that Pietra and I would beat up on DJ. Now the two of you are siding up against me.
我以为皮特拉会和我一起教训DJ。现在你们两个站到他对立面去了。
All right.
好吧。
There's a couple thoughts I have. My thought was that the global economy needs me more, but I guess you're saying that's not necessarily true.
我有几个想法。我以为全球经济更需要我，但我想你说那不一定是真的。
Do you know how hard it is? You know how many lawyers within probably two miles of my house? I don't know how many people I have-- I've got thousands of lawyers and I don't think I have a single person that I'd trust the wiring in my house to. And if somebody on that construction site that DJ is working is going to work their way up to supervisor and foreman and so forth and so on. And some will not.
你知道这有多难吗？你知道在我家附近两英里内有多少律师吗？我不知道我有多少人——我有成千上万的律师，我觉得没有一个人是我敢把家里的线路交给他们做的。如果建筑工地上的某个人像DJ那样努力工作，晋升为领班、工头等等。有些人会这样做，有些人不会。
Yeah, I do have more to offer. I can do landscaping. I can do electrical work. What else? Woodwork. I can do cabinets.
是的，我确实有更多能提供的东西。我可以做景观设计。我可以做电气工作。还有什么？木工。我可以做橱柜。
And you're really good people person.
你确实是个很擅长与人打交道的人。
Yeah.
是的。
I feel like I could see you as a leader.
我觉得我能看到你作为领导者的潜质。
I'm a social butterfly.
我是个社交蝴蝶。
These are great skills in any economy. The guys I worry about, actually, are not people who sound like DJ. The guys I worry about are the guys who have worked in that same plant doing more or less the same job in the auto factory for 30 years and now the plant closes and now what have they got? That, I think, is a bigger challenge. They're much more at risk in this global economy.
在任何经济环境下，这些都是很棒的技能。我真正担心的那些人，其实不是像DJ这样的人。我担心的那些人是已经在同一家工厂干了30年，做着基本相同工作的汽车工厂工人，现在工厂倒闭了，他们还能干什么？我认为那是一个更大的挑战。在这个全球经济中，他们面临的风险要大得多。
Before we talked, I was thinking about our family. And I was thinking the people who went to college, I feel like there's--
在我们谈话之前，我想到了我们的家人。我以为那些上过大学的人，我觉得有——
Very successful.
非常成功。
But more anxious, also. DJ has a pretty awesome life, right? I mean, it's stable, it's fun, you leave your work at the workplace and you're off and you're having a good time.
但更焦虑。DJ的生活其实很棒，对吧？我的意思是，它很稳定，很有趣，你在工作场所之外就把工作忘得一干二净，然后你就可以出去玩得开心。
Oh yeah. I never talk about work when I'm not working. I make an exception for you, though.
哦，是的。我不在工作时从来不谈论工作。不过为你我破例一次。
All right. Thanks.
好的。谢谢。
Well, my brother quit high school. And he has a very nice life. He lives on a boat in Florida. And he does marine carpentry and on any given day, if you looked at the two of us, I think it would look like he's having a better time.
嗯，我弟弟高中退学了。他过着非常美好的生活。他住在佛罗里达的一艘船上。他做海洋木工，随便哪天你看看我们俩，我觉得看起来他过得比我好。
I thought what we were going to learn in this conversation-- and it turns out I was totally wrong. What I thought they were going to learn is--
我以为我们会在这次谈话中了解到——结果我完全错了。我以为他们会了解到的是——
That I was wrong?
我错了？
That DJ's wrong, I'm right, and he should go to college. And that's just obvious and his life is going to get worse and worse. That is clearly not what we've learned.
是DJ错了，我是对的，他应该去上大学。这显而易见，他的生活会变得越来越糟。显然我们了解到的根本不是这样。
Good.
太好了。
But that's because you and I have these snotty biases.
但那是因为你和我都有这些势利的偏见。
Right.
对。
Ooh.
喔。
That's true.
那是真的。
Right? No, I share them.
对吧？不，我也有。
Yeah
是啊。
Everyone does. It's no big deal.
每个人都有。这没什么大不了的。
I can't wait to see DJ and treat him with my newfound respect.
我迫不及待地想见到DJ，并用我新发现的敬意来对待他。
Nice.
很好。
Maybe we should-- yeah, we should just talk every couple years and--
也许我们应该——是的，我们应该每隔几年谈一次——
Yeah, and follow his progress. I'd like to do that.
是的，追踪他的进步。我很想这样做。
That would be really nice.
那会非常棒。
And ours, Adam.
还有我们的，亚当。
Right, and ours. Right, when my job is outsourced and DJ has a really good construction gig and I'm trying really hard to get him to hire me.
对，还有我们的。对，当我的工作被外包而DJ有了一份很好的建筑工作，我还在努力让他雇用我时。
You're already hired.
你已经被雇用了。
Thanks, man.
谢谢，伙计。
Adam Davidson is learning new things about the economy all the time and telling the world on NPR News and on the Planet Money podcast.
亚当·戴维森一直在这个不断学习关于经济的新知识，并在NPR新闻和Planet Money播客上向世界讲述。
Act Two, Does This Suit Make Me Look Terrorist to You?
第二幕，这套西装让我看起来像恐怖分子吗？
My name is Rany Jazayerli. I'm a doctor. I'm a physician here in the suburbs of Chicago. I'm a dermatologist.
我叫拉尼·扎扎耶利。我是一名医生。我是芝加哥郊区的一名医生。我是一名皮肤科医生。
Which is to say that Rany Jazayerli is not in politics. He's not a pundit. He's not a public figure. But this past fall, during the 2008 election, something happened to a friend of his, something that made Rany feel like he and his friend were swimming against the tide of history. And in his frustration, Rany wrote an essay that ended up in the election coverage at this website that was a favorite for political junkies-- FiveThirtyEight.com
也就是说，拉尼·扎扎耶利不搞政治。他不是评论员。他不是公众人物。但在去年秋天，2008年大选期间，他的一个朋友发生了一些事，这让拉尼觉得他和他的朋友正在逆历史潮流而行。出于挫败感，拉尼写了一篇文章，最后被登在了深受政治迷欢迎的网站FiveThirtyEight.com的竞选报道中。
Even though the election is passed, the essay still seemed relevant today and we invited him in to read it. Basically, what happened is that candidate, Barack Obama, hired Randy's friend Mazen Asbahi to be the campaign's national coordinator for Muslim-American affairs. And then, after just 10 days in this job, The Wall Street Journal ran a story that stated uncritically all kinds of rumors against Asbahi and explained that because of these rumors, Mazen Asbahi was resigning from the campaign. Here's what Rany wrote.
尽管选举已经过去，但这篇文章今天仍然显得很有意义，我们邀请他来阅读它。基本上，发生的事情是，候选人巴拉克·奥巴马聘请了拉尼的朋友马赞·阿斯巴希担任竞选活动的美国穆斯林事务国家协调员。然后，在担任该职位的仅仅10天后，《华尔街日报》发表了一篇报道，不加批判地陈述了各种关于阿斯巴希的谣言，并解释说由于这些谣言，马赞·阿斯巴希正在辞去竞选团队的职务。这是拉尼写的。
Mazen Asbahi is one of my best friends. Our kids play together and we dine together at least once a month. We're close. And now, thanks to the work of some racist jerkwads, his reputation has been sullied from coast to coast. So I'm crushed for him as a friend, but I'm furious as a Muslim because what has happened is that Mazen was forced to resign because of a smear campaign that targeted him for the sin of being Muslim. Nothing more, nothing less.
马赞·阿斯巴希是我最好的朋友之一。我们的孩子一起玩，我们每个月至少聚餐一次。我们很亲密。而现在，多亏了一些种族主义混蛋的工作，他的名声从东海岸到西海岸都被玷污了。所以我为他作为朋友感到心碎，但我作为一名穆斯林感到愤怒，因为发生的事情是，马赞被迫辞职，是因为一场针对他身为穆斯林这一“罪行”的抹黑运动。别无其他。
Let's parse the original Wall Street Journal column, if you don't mind. It says, quote, "In 2000, Mr. Asbahi briefly served on the board of Allied Asset Advisors Fund. Its other board members at the time included Jamal Said, the imam at a fundamentalist-controlled mosque in Illinois." Quote, 'I served on that board for only a few weeks before resigning as soon as I became aware of public allegations against another member of the board,' Mr. Asbahi said in his resignation letter. 'Since concerns have been raised about that brief time, I am stepping down to avoid distracting from Barack Obama's message of change'."
如果你不介意的话，让我们解析一下《华尔街日报》最初的那篇专栏文章。它写道，引用：“2000年，阿斯巴希先生曾在联合资产顾问基金的董事会短暂任职。当时的董事会成员包括贾马尔·赛义德，伊利诺伊州一家受原教旨主义控制的清真寺的伊玛目。”引用：“在成为董事会另一名成员面临公开指控后，我意识到这一点并立即辞职，只在那个董事会任职了几个星期，”阿斯巴希先生在辞职信中说。“由于关于那段短暂时间引发了担忧，我正在辞职，以避免分散巴拉克·奥巴马变革信息的注意力。”
Where do I start? Let's start with Jamal Said, the imam at a fundamentalist-controlled mosque. The consensus of the vast majority of Muslims in Chicago is that the mosque is not a fundamentalist anything, which is why it has such a large membership. Some of the mosque's more recent projects include donating a riverfront garden to the City of Chicago-- there's a picture of Mayor Richard Daley at the ribbon cutting ceremony-- and becoming the first mosque in the country to run on solar power.
我从哪儿开始呢？让我们从贾马尔·赛义德开始，那个受原教旨主义控制的清真寺的伊玛目。芝加哥绝大多数穆斯林的共识是，那座清真寺根本不是什么原教旨主义的地方，这就是它拥有如此多会员的原因。该清真寺最近的一些项目包括向芝加哥市捐赠一个河畔花园——有理查德·戴利市长在剪彩仪式上的照片——并成为全国第一座完全由太阳能供电的清真寺。
Said has never been convicted of any crime nor arrested for any crime nor indicted for any crime. He has been accused of supporting Hamas but has never been found guilty of anything. I'm not here to defend Said. I don't know him. But the point is that Said is not a convicted criminal or a mafia don that walks the streets while people cower in fear. What he is is the imam of the largest mosque in the Chicago area. Mazen is an active member of the Muslim community here in Chicago. It would be almost impossible for him to be active and not have some contact with Said.
赛义德从未被判犯有任何罪行，也从未因任何罪行被捕或被起诉。他被指控支持哈马斯，但从未被发现有任何过错。我不是来为赛义德辩护的。我不认识他。但重点是，赛义德不是一个在人们瑟瑟发抖时走在大街上的被定罪的罪犯或黑手党头目。他是一个芝加哥地区最大的清真寺的伊玛目。马赞是芝加哥穆斯林社区的一名活跃成员。对他来说，要活跃而不与赛义德有任何接触几乎是不可能的。
So Mazen that happened to serve on the board of an investment fund with Said until he learned about allegations that Said had been involved in raising funds for Hamas, at which time he quit the board. In 2000, before 9-11, before Iraq, before the US government shut down Muslim charities after accusing them of funneling money to Hamas and other designated terrorist groups. But in 2000, before our own government felt that these charitable activities were illegal, Mazen decided to dissociate himself from even the hint of impropriety. That doesn't support accusations that he's a terrorist sympathizer. It refutes them.
所以，马赞碰巧在一家投资基金的董事会与赛义德一起任职，直到他了解到有关赛义德涉嫌参与为哈马斯筹款的指控，在那时他退出了董事会。在2000年，在9·11之前，在伊拉克战争之前，在美国政府在指控穆斯林慈善机构向哈马斯和其他被指定的恐怖组织输送资金后将其关闭之前。但在2000年，在我们政府自己认为这些慈善活动非法之前，马赞就决定让自己远离哪怕一丝不正当的嫌疑。这并不能支持他是恐怖分子同情者的指控。它反驳了这些指控。
The Wall Street Journal column continues, quote, "The Justice Department named Mr. Said an unindicted co-conspirator in the racketeering trial last year of several alleged Hamas fundraisers, which ended in a mistrial," unquote. Pardon my Arabic, but what the [BLEEP] is an unindicted co-conspirator and why is our government using this phrase? Whatever happened to innocent until proven guilty? And whatever happened to the notion that indictment is just the first step towards a guilty verdict? A prosecutor is supposed to be able to indict a ham sandwich. So what does it say that they've never been able to indict Said?
《华尔街日报》的专栏文章继续写道，引用：“司法部去年将赛义德先生列为多名涉嫌哈马斯筹款人的敲诈勒索案审判中的未被起诉的同谋，该审判以无效审判告终，”引文结束。原谅我的阿拉伯语，但那[哔]是什么未被起诉的同谋，为什么我们的政府在使用这个词组？无罪推定原则去哪儿了？任何关于起诉只是迈向有罪判决的第一步的概念去哪儿了？检察官应该能够起诉火腿三明治。那么他们从未能起诉赛义德说明了什么？
In that racketeering trial, which again, ended in a mistrial, the government listed close to 300 Muslim organizations as unindicted co-conspirators, which is tantamount to saying, we think some of them are terrorists and since we don't know who, we'll just blame them all. So much for innocent until proven guilty. This isn't even guilty until proven innocent. It's guilty with no recourse to prove you're innocent. How can you defend yourself against an indictment which doesn't exist? Said is guilty by association, which makes Mazen, apparently guilty by association with someone who's guilty by association. It's McCarthyism, squared.
在那场敲诈勒索审判中，再次强调，以无效审判告终，政府列出了近300个穆斯林组织作为未被起诉的同谋，这等于说，我们认为其中一些是恐怖分子，既然我们不知道是谁，我们就会把他们全都归咎。无罪推定原则就到此为止了。这甚至不是“被证明有罪前是无辜的”。这是没有证明自己清白的追索权的“有罪”。你如何为针对一个不存在的起诉进行辩护？赛义德因为联想而有罪，这使得马赞，显然因为与一个因为联想而有罪的人联想而有罪。这是麦卡锡主义的平方。
Oh, and you know who else is associated with Said? As Jake Tapper of ABC News pointed out, the board that Mazen and Said both sat on was the Allied Asset Advisor Funds, a subsidiary of the North American Islamic Trust, or NAIT. NAIT is an adviser to the Dow Jones Islamic Fund-- Dow Jones, which publishes the Wall Street Journal , which broke the story that forced Mazen's resignation. We're officially through the looking glass, people.
哦，你知道还有谁和赛义德有联系吗？正如美国广播公司新闻的杰克·塔珀所指出的，马赞和赛义德都所在的董事会是联合资产顾问基金，是北美伊斯兰信托（NAIT）的子公司。NAIT是道琼斯伊斯兰基金的顾问——道琼斯，出版了披露这起迫使马赞辞职的故事的《华尔街日报》。人们，我们正式穿过了镜子。
I'm so angry I don't know where to direct my anger. What The Wall Street Journal is saying is that Mazen Asbahi has a link to people suspected of terrorism. What I'll tell you is this-- Mazen is not a terrorist. He's not a fundamentalist. He's not an Islamist. The only thing he is guilty of is being a Muslim and being an active member of the Muslim community. If he wasn't, he wouldn't have been qualified for the position in the first place. As Ahmed Rehab put it in today's Chicago Tribune , the headline should read, Muslim Liaison for Presidential Campaign Resigns After Connections to Muslim Community Are Found. If Mazen Asbahi is a terrorist, than I am a terrorist. And if I were named to the same position, I'm sure they would have found a way to label me a terrorist as well.
我愤怒到不知道该把怒火指向哪里。《华尔街日报》所说的是，马赞·阿斯巴希与涉嫌恐怖主义的人有联系。我要告诉你的是这个——马赞不是恐怖分子。他不是原教旨主义者。他不是伊斯兰主义者。他唯一犯的罪就是身为穆斯林并成为穆斯林社区的活跃成员。如果不是这样，他起初就不具备担任该职位的资格。正如艾哈迈德·里哈布在今天的《芝加哥论坛报》中所说，头条新闻应该写着，总统竞选活动的穆斯林联络人在发现其与穆斯林社区的联系后辞职。如果马赞·阿斯巴希是恐怖分子，那我就是恐怖分子。如果我被提名为同一个职位，我相信他们也会找到办法把我标记为恐怖分子。
And that's what this is about. The same people who claim there is no such thing as a moderate Muslim will do everything in their power to slander people like Mazen Asbahi-- the epitome of a moderate, modern, integrated, tolerant, patriotic, American Muslim-- as an extremist, they will set their sights on any Muslim who seeks to be a part of the political process and will pick them off one by one until there are no more targets left. If Obama won't stand up to the flimsiest of accusations linking someone in his campaign to terrorists, however remotely and ridiculously, I'm not sure what he'll stand up against.
这就是这件事的意义所在。那些声称不存在温和派穆斯林的人，会竭尽全力诽谤像马赞·阿斯巴希这样的人——温和、现代、融入、宽容、爱国的美国穆斯林的缩影——为极端分子，他们会将目标锁定在任何寻求参与政治进程的穆斯林身上，并将他们一个一个地剔除，直到没有目标为止。如果奥巴马不能站出来对抗那些将他竞选团队中的某人与恐怖分子联系起来的、无论多么遥远和荒谬的轻率指控，我不确定他还会站出来对抗什么。
The world is at war right now, but it's not a war of Christian versus Muslim. It's a war of moderates versus extremists and the two groups are battling it out in places like Iraq and Afghanistan. But they're also battling here in America. This week, the extremists won.
世界现在正处于战争状态，但这不是基督教对抗穆斯林的战争。这是温和派对抗极端分子的战争，两派正在伊拉克和阿富汗等地进行战斗。但他们也在美国境内战斗。本周，极端分子赢了。
Rany Jazayerli. In the many weeks since he wrote that essay, first, the Obama campaign hired another coordinator for Muslim-American outreach and the same exact thing happened to her. She was accused of meeting with Muslim leaders who were suspected of terrorist sympathies with no proof of those sympathies. It didn't actually get to the point where she had to resign, but seeing it happen again did make Rany a little more understanding of what the Obama campaign was up against and a little less mad at them.
拉尼·扎扎耶利。在他写那篇文章后的许多周里，首先，奥巴马竞选团队聘请了另一位穆斯林裔美国人联络协调员，同样的事情也发生在她的身上。她被指控会见涉嫌支持恐怖主义的穆斯林领袖，但没有任何证据证明这些同情。她实际上并没有到被迫辞职的地步，但再次看到这种情况发生确实让拉尼对奥巴马竞选团队所面临的困境有了更多的理解，对他们的愤怒也少了一些。
After that, as perhaps you've heard, the Obama campaign won the presidency. Rany's friend Mazen is hoping that he may end up getting a job with the Obama administration.
此后，正如你可能听说的那样，奥巴马竞选团队赢得了总统大选。拉尼的朋友马赞希望他最终能得到一份奥巴马政府的工作。
Act Three, Family Feudalism. All right, ready cue trumpets? Cue trumpets.
第三幕，家族封建主义。好了，准备好小号了吗？小号响起来。
Welcome to America's favorite game show. It's time to make your phone call to the 14th century. I'm your host, Chip McMartin. What information will our three lucky contestants share with the people of the Middle Ages? Let's find out. Your first contestant, ladies and gentlemen, Gregory [? Palcapo. ?] Hi, Greg.
欢迎来到美国最受欢迎的游戏节目。是时候拨打你的电话给14世纪了。我是主持人，奇普·麦克马丁。我们的三位幸运参赛者会与中世纪的人们分享什么信息呢？让我们来看看。女士们先生们，您的第一位参赛者，格雷戈里·[？帕尔卡波？]。你好，格雷。
Hi, Chip.
你好，奇普。
Welcome to Phone Call to the 14th Century. Says here on the card that you want to be a race car driver.
欢迎参加拨打14世纪电话。卡片上说你想成为一名赛车手。
I do but I can't.
我想，但我不能。
OK, well, you know the rules. This phone is connected to a phone in a hut somewhere in the 14th century. You've got 30 seconds to impart as much useful information as you can to the people back then. What are you going to tell them?
好的，你知道规则。这部电话连接到14世纪某个地方的一间小屋的电话。你有30秒的时间向那时的人们传达尽可能多有用的信息。你要告诉他们什么？
I think I'm going to focus on hygiene and stuff.
我想我会专注于卫生之类的事情。
Good luck. Ready, phone call, begin.
祝你好运。准备好，电话开始。
Hi, this is Gregory [? Palcapo, ?] talking machines from the 21st century. Don't be scared, OK? Write everything down. Wash your hands. Boil your water. There's no such thing as witches. Everybody floats.
嗨，我是格雷戈里·[？帕尔卡波？]，21世纪的谈话机器。别害怕，好吗？把一切写下来。洗手。把水煮沸。没有女巫这回事。每个人都会漂浮。
Monkeys are cousins of God. Pass. Monkeys are cousins of humans. The finches had different beaks to pick up stuff. A fish walked out of the water. He could talk. That means there's no God.
猴子是上帝的表亲。跳过。猴子是人类的表亲。雀鸟有不同的喙来捡东西。鱼从水里走出来。它会说话。这意味着没有上帝。
Dig up oil. it's a black syrup in the ground. Light it on fire. Make a motorcycle. Make a factory. Don't throw away the middle of the donut. You can sell it. Go to Egypt. There's a bunch of mummies and gold. It's yours for the taking. Some of the popes are evil. Some of the popes are evil.
挖石油。它是地下的黑色糖浆。点火。制造摩托车。建立工厂。不要扔掉甜甜圈的中间部分。你可以卖掉它。去埃及。那里有一堆木乃伊和黄金。那是你的，随便拿。有些教皇是邪恶的。有些教皇是邪恶的。
Some of the popes are evil indeed. Ladies and gentlemen, let's see what our judges say about that. And they're going to give you 12 and a half major concepts. That puts you in good standing. Let's meet our first challenger. Please welcome Blaine Cardoza. Hi, Blaine.
确实有些教皇是邪恶的。女士们先生们，让我们看看评委们怎么说。他们会给你12个半主要概念。这让你处于有利地位。让我们见见我们的第一位挑战者。请欢迎布莱恩·卡多扎。你好，布莱恩。
Hi.
嗨。
You ready to make your phone call to the 14th century?
你准备好打那个电话给14世纪了吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
You think you can beat Greg?
你觉得你能打败格雷吗？
I have a secret weapon, Chip.
奇普，我有秘密武器。
Oh you do? You want to give us a hint?
哦，真的吗？想给我们一个提示吗？
Let's just say it rhymes with piddle pinglish.
我只能说它听起来像“中世纪英语”。
OK. Ready, phone call, begin.
好的。准备好，电话开始。
Whan that Aprill, with his shoures soote
当那四月，带着它那柔和的细雨，
The global warming hath perced to the roote
全球变暖刺穿了根部，
And bathed the omega-3 fatty acids in the flour,
并浸浴了面粉中的欧米茄-3脂肪酸，
When Zephyrus eek with his antibiotics, such as penicillin
当西风和它的抗生素，比如青霉素，
Hath in every holt and heeth
在每一个灌木丛和荒原，
The plug-in hybrid, and the yonge sonne
插电式混合动力车，和年轻的太阳，
Hath in the Ram his halfe
在白羊座它的一半，
[? Five seconds, Blaine.
[？还有五秒，布莱恩。
halfe-- half hour pizza delivery or your money back.
半——半小时披萨送达，否则退款。
Time's up. Blaine Cardoza, that was incredible. Are you sure you didn't just make that up?
时间到了。布莱恩·卡多扎，那真是太不可思议了。你确定你不是编的吗？
No, I'm fluent in Middle English.
不，我精通中世纪英语。
Then how would you say hi mom?
那你会怎么说“嗨，妈妈”？
Hi, [? eh-- mummy?
嗨，[？嗯——木乃伊？
OK, well, what do our judges say? And they say that's correct. They're going to give you nine and a half major concepts. Another incredible score. Ladies and gentlemen, what will it take from your final challenger? Let's meet him, Donald Darndy. Hi, Don.
好吧，评委们怎么说？他们说那是正确的。他们会给你九个半主要概念。另一个令人难以置信的得分。女士们先生们，最终的挑战者会带来什么？让我们见见他，唐纳德·达恩迪。你好，唐。
Hi, Chip.
嗨，奇普。
What are you going to tell the people of the 14th century?
你要告诉14世纪的人们什么？
I'm just going to focus on being a teacher like I am right here on earth.
我就专注于做一名老师，就像我在这里地球上一样。
Well, it's the same planet, Don, just a different century. Ready, phone call, begin.
嗯，那是同一个星球，唐，只是不同的世纪。准备好，电话开始。
This is Don Darndy, teacher from the future. OK, first of all, always believe in yourself. Never give up your dreams or they'll give up on you. The bubonic plague-- it might seem bad now, but you'll look back on it and laugh.
这是唐·达恩迪，来自未来的老师。好的，首先，永远相信自己。永远不要放弃你的梦想，否则它们会放弃你。鼠疫——现在看来可能很糟糕，但你会回头嘲笑它。
You're losing, Don.
唐，你快输了。
OK, forget it. I want you to do something for me now. Get some coins, a suit of armor, any old books you don't want, any tapestries, anything with a unicorn on it. Put it in a box and write my name on it-- Donald Darndy. Give the the box to Christopher Columbus. Tell Columbus to give it to Lewis and Clark. Have them leave the box at the Elks Lodge in Modesto, California.
好的，算了吧。我现在要你为我做点事。拿些硬币，一副盔甲，任何你不想要的旧书，任何挂毯，任何有独角兽的东西。把它放在盒子里，写上我的名字——唐纳德·达恩迪。把盒子交给克里斯托弗·哥伦布。告诉哥伦布把它交给刘易斯和克拉克。让他们把盒子留在加利福尼亚州莫德斯托的麋鹿会馆。
Oh, Don. You told them to send you a bunch of stuff from the Middle Ages?
哦，唐。你让他们给你送一堆中世纪的东西？
It'll get here.
它会到的。
Wouldn't it have gotten here already.
难道它不会早就到了吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Let's see what our judges say, and they're going to give you 0.023 major concepts. It's not enough to beat Greg, who becomes our new champion and millionaire. Congratulations. And ladies and gentlemen, come see use next week when we make our Phone Call to the 14th Century.
让我们看看评委们怎么说，他们会给你0.023个主要概念。这不足以打败格雷，他成为了我们的新冠军和百万富翁。恭喜。女士们先生们，下周再来见我们，我们将拨打14世纪电话。
That was the San Francisco comedy group Kasper Hauser. Their latest book, Weddings of the Times , a parody of the New York Times wedding pages, comes out this May. You can find more of their comedy online at www.kasperhauser.com.
那是旧金山的喜剧团体卡斯帕·豪瑟。他们最新的书，《时代婚礼》，是对《纽约时报》婚礼版的恶搞，将在今年五月出版。你可以在网上找到更多他们的喜剧，网址是www.kasperhauser.com。
Coming up, it takes 61 years to build up a reputation and, when you are on the wrong side of history, just seven weeks to destroy it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，建立名声需要61年，而当你站在历史的错误一边时，摧毁它只需要七周。节目将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, stories of people who think they are stuck on the wrong side of history. We've arrived at Act Four of our show.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目，关于那些认为自己被困在历史错误一边的故事。我们已经来到了节目的第四幕。
Act Four, The Other Guy. If you've never lived in Chicago, chances are you don't have much idea about what Harold Washington meant to the city. Washington became the city's first black mayor in 1983. And it caused a historic change. Before Harold-- and everybody called him Harold-- even basic city services like garbage collection were worse in black neighborhoods. Chicago was the city where race relations were so bad Martin Luther King give up on it back in the 1960s.
第四幕，另一个人。如果你从来没有住在芝加哥，你可能不太了解哈罗德·华盛顿对这个城市意味着什么。华盛顿在1983年成为该市第一位黑人市长。这引起了历史性的变化。在哈罗德之前——每个人都叫他哈罗德——即使是基本的城市服务，比如垃圾收集，在黑人社区也更糟糕。芝加哥是一个种族关系如此糟糕，以至于马丁·路德·金在1960年代就放弃了这个城市。
Barack Obama moved to Chicago after Harold took office, and in his book, Dreams from My Father , Obama writes about how people talked about their new black mayor, quote, "with a familiarity and affection normally reserved for a relative." "Had to be here before Harold to understand what he means to this city," an old timer tells Obama. "Before Harold, seems like we'd always been second-class citizens-- plantation politics, police brutality rampant." Harold set things so that for the first time, white and black citizens were treated the same by the city government, but is remembered just as much for his charisma. He was eloquent, he was personable, he did not mince words.
巴拉克·奥巴马在哈罗德上任后搬到了芝加哥，在书《我父亲的梦想》中，奥巴马写道人们是如何谈论他们的新黑人市长的，引用：“带着通常保留给亲戚的那种熟悉感和亲情。”“必须在哈罗德之前来到这里，才能理解他对于这个城市意味着什么，”一位老住户告诉奥巴马。“在哈罗德之前，似乎我们一直是二等公民——种植园政治，警察暴力猖獗。”哈罗德设定了这些，使得白人和黑人公民第一次受到市政府的平等对待，但人们同样记得他的个人魅力。他能言善辩，平易近人，直言不讳。
You pick up a local paper and these guys just wax so eloquently. They don't know what the hell they're talking about. They don't have the slightest idea about the phenomena, don't understand the history, don't understand the mindset, don't understand what push people. All they say is, gee, black folks must be angry. Gee, black folks vote for black folks. They must hate white folks. Ain't got nothing to do with nothing. Nothing. Crazy stuff.
你拿起当地的一份报纸，这些家伙说得如此动听。他们根本不知道自己在说什么。他们对现象没有任何了解，不懂历史，不懂心态，不懂什么推动了人们。他们所说的只是，天哪，黑人一定很生气。天哪，黑人投票给黑人。他们一定恨白人。这与任何事情都无关。什么都没有。疯狂的东西。
So Harold was this historic figure for the city. The big library downtown and a college are named after him. One of the first hour-long stories we ever did on our program was about him. So imagine for a second what it was like to be the guy who he ran against and who he beat in an historic election back in the 1980s.
所以哈罗德是这个城市的一个历史性人物。市中心的大型图书馆和一所学院都以他的名字命名。我们节目中做过的第一个长达一小时的故事就是关于他的。所以试想一下，成为他竞选对手，并他在1980年代的一场历史性选举中击败的那个人，会是什么样子。
Well, that guy was a Republican named Bernie Epton. And for anybody who actually remembers him, Epton is known not just for being the white opponent for the city's first black mayor, he's also remembered for the way his campaign was fought. It was not pretty. The campaign did not quash the racial tension in the city. It unleashed it in all its fury.
嗯，那个人是一个名叫伯尼·埃普顿的共和党人。对于任何真正记得他的人来说，埃普顿不仅以成为该市第一位黑人市长的白人对手而闻名，他还因他的竞选方式而被人们记住。那并不漂亮。竞选活动并没有平息城市的种族紧张局势。它彻底释放了所有的愤怒。
Reporter Alex Kotlowitz, who lives in Chicago, found himself recently revisiting the Epton story. One of Epton's political peers once called Epton The Accidental Racist, though as Alex points out, there's more to him that the way the most Chicagoans think of him.
住在芝加哥的记者亚历克斯·科特洛维茨最近发现自己正在重温埃普顿的故事。埃普顿的一位政治同僚曾称埃普顿为“意外的种族主义者”，尽管正如亚历克斯指出的那样，关于他，还有比大多数芝加哥人认为的更多的东西。
I thought of Bernie Epton this past October while watching John McCain. The parallels with the Epton-Washington race were eerie-- a white Republican with a reputation as a principled guy waging an increasingly bitter fight against a charismatic black opponent. The details of the two races were widely different-- different men, different eras. But both candidates seem like actors miscast as the heavy and then surprised to find themselves stuck in that role.
去年十月观看约翰·麦凯恩时，我想到了伯尼·埃普顿。与埃普顿-华盛顿竞选的相似之处令人毛骨悚然——一位以原则性著称的白人共和党人，正在与一位有魅力的黑人对手进行日益激烈的斗争。两场竞选的细节迥然不同——不同的人，不同的时代。但这两位候选人都像是被选错角色的演员，然后惊讶地发现自己被困在了那个角色里。
Epton, like McCain, was his own man. He was an iconoclast, not afraid to poke fun at himself.
埃普顿和麦凯恩一样，是他自己。他是一个偶像破坏者，不怕拿自己开玩笑。
Mr. Epton--
埃普顿先生——
Thank you.
谢谢。
--Republican candidates are supposedly low profile in Chicago, but it was pointed out to me that there was a feature piece done on you in People Magazine , I guess, this is week or-- that might be the most exposure any Republican's ever had in Chicago.
——共和党候选人在芝加哥通常很低调，但有人指出在《人物》杂志上有一篇关于你的专题文章，我想，这是这一周或者——那可能是芝加哥任何共和党人有过的最大曝光。
Well, actually, I think that they got lost. They didn't realize I was Republican until they finished. Otherwise, I'm sure they wouldn't have gone ahead with it.
嗯，实际上，我想他们是迷路了。他们直到最后才意识到我是共和党人。否则，我相信他们不会继续下去的。
There's a reason people might not have known Epton was a Republican. He was this unusually progressive guy, an early opponent of McCarthyism. And when he served in the state legislature, one of his law partners says that he was so pro-consumer that it ticked off some of their law clients-- insurance companies. And on the race question, he was clear about where he stood. He marched in Memphis with the sanitation workers after Dr. King's assassination. He sat on this board of an old age home for African-American women. And as a state rep for 14 years, he fought redlining.
人们可能不知道埃普顿是共和党人是有原因的。他是一个不同寻常的进步人士，是早期麦卡锡主义的反对者。当他在州立法机构任职时，他的一个法律合伙人说，他非常亲消费者，以至于惹恼了一些他们的法律客户——保险公司。而在种族问题上，他很清楚自己的立场。在马丁·路德·金博士遇刺后，他随环卫工人在孟菲斯游行。他曾担任非裔美国妇女养老院董事会成员。作为州众议员14年，他一直与红线划定作斗争。
Even in his personal life, his principles guided him. His son Jeff went to Hyde Park High School, where he was one of only a handful of white students in his freshman class.
即使在他的个人生活中，他的原则也指引着他。他的儿子杰夫就读于海德公园高中，他是他新生班级中仅有的几名白人学生之一。
For years, we'd watched people move out of the neighborhood to the North Side or to the suburbs to get their children away from what was becoming a majority black school district. Dad never did that. This stuff mattered to him absolutely and he believed that if you moved out of the city-- if white, middle-class families left-- it was a betrayal.
多年来，我们看着人们搬出社区去北区或郊区，让他们的孩子远离那个正在变成黑人多数的学区。爸爸从不那样做。这些东西对他绝对重要，他相信如果你搬出城市——如果白人中产阶级家庭离开了——那是一种背叛。
Bernie Epton did not set out to oppose the first serious black mayoral candidate in Chicago's history. In fact, when he got the Republican nomination, the Democratic primary was still up in the air. It was a three-way race among Harold Washington, Jane Byrne, and Richard Daley. He thought he'd be running against either Byrne or Daley and he knew we didn't have much of a chance.
伯尼·埃普顿并没有打算反对芝加哥历史上第一位严肃的黑人市长候选人。事实上，当他获得共和党提名时，民主党初选仍在进行中。这是一场在哈罗德·华盛顿、简·伯恩和理查德·戴利之间的三方竞选。他以为他会与伯恩或戴利中的一个竞争，他知道我们没什么机会。
Chicago, for decades, has been a thoroughly Democratic city. In the previous mayoral election in 1979, the Democratic candidate received 82% of the vote, so Epton knew he didn't stand a chance. And that was OK. This was the ritual, that a Republican candidate would run their perfunctory campaign and use it, maybe, as a chance to raise some issues.
几十年来，芝加哥一直是一个彻底的民主党城市。在1979年的上一次市长选举中，民主党候选人获得了82%的选票，所以埃普顿知道他没有机会。而那没关系。这是一个仪式，共和党候选人会进行他们的敷衍式竞选，并利用它，也许，作为一个提出一些问题的机会。
Does it matter to you what happens tonight in the Democratic primary?
今晚民主党初选发生的事情对你重要吗？
Not at all. I think any one of the three will be extremely difficult to defeat.
一点也不。我认为他们三个中的任何一个都将极难被击败。
But on primary night, everything suddenly changed. As it became increasingly clear that Harold Washington-- not Byrne or Daley-- would be Upton's Democratic opponent.
但在初选之夜，一切突然改变了。随着哈罗德·华盛顿——而不是伯恩或戴利——将成为埃普顿的民主党对手，这一点变得越来越清楚。
So many people are saying if Harold Washington wins, the white people will be afraid and they will then vote for you and that improves your chances.
很多人都在说，如果哈罗德·华盛顿赢了，白人会感到害怕，然后他们会投票给你，这增加了你的机会。
Well, I resent that very much. I think that Harold Washington and I, if he is a winner, I am positive that we will come out with a joint statement, perhaps speak together to repudiate it. I don't want to be elected because I'm white and Harold doesn't want to be elected because he's black. I want to be elected because I'm the best qualified.
嗯，我非常愤慨。我认为哈罗德·华盛顿和我，如果他是赢家，我确信我们会发表联合声明，也许一起说话来抵制它。我不想因为我是白人而当选，哈罗德也不想因为他是黑人而当选。我想因为我是最合格的而当选。
Epton sounds certain about how he's going to run his campaign-- with honor, with principles. But once it became clear that Washington, a black man, was his opponent, everyone-- and I mean everyone, people in the neighborhoods to the operatives in the national republican party to Bernie Epton himself-- instinctually knew that now Epton actually had a chance to win.
埃普顿听起来很确定他将如何进行竞选——带着荣誉，带着原则。但一旦明确华盛顿，一个黑人，是他的对手时，每个人——我是说每个人，从社区的人到国家共和党机构的操作人员，再到伯尼·埃普顿自己——直觉上都知道，现在埃普顿确实有机会获胜。
One of the people working on his campaign was his daughter, Dale. She was there when national Republican operatives showed up in Chicago from Washington with money and ideas.
为他的竞选工作的人之一是他的女儿，戴尔。当国家共和党操作人员带着钱和想法从华盛顿来到芝加哥时，她在场。
As much as they were supposedly working for us, as soon as the people from D.C. came down, we had a new campaign slogan, which we got a lot of flak for.
虽然他们理应为我们工作，但当来自华盛顿特区的人下来时，我们有了一个新的竞选口号，我们因此受到了很多批评。
And that slogan was,
那个口号是，
Epton for mayor before it's too late.
“埃普顿市长，为时未晚”。
This slogan-- "before it's too late"-- became infamous, not only in Chicago but around the country. Its meaning seemed transparent, but not to Epton. Epton insisted, both in public and in private, that "before it's too late" plainly refer to Chicago's financial problems.
这个口号——“为时未晚”——变得臭名昭著，不仅在芝加哥，而且在全国各地。它的含义似乎是透明的，但对埃普顿来说并非如此。埃普顿坚持认为，无论是在公共场合还是私下里，“为时未晚”明确指的是芝加哥的财政问题。
And we thought "Upton-- before it's too late," because of a fiscal situation, you know, we didn't see anything else with that slogan. Apparently a lot of other people did. They felt it was a racist saying that we were saying, before an Afro-American would be elected mayor, that it was intended to show that my father was white and Harold was black.
我们想“埃普顿——为时未晚”，因为财政状况，你知道，我们没有从那个口号中看到任何其他东西。显然，很多人看到了。他们觉得这是一个种族主义口号，我们是在说，在一位非裔美国人当选市长之前，它旨在表明我父亲是白人，哈罗德是黑人。
Dale, do you think that the people from Washington who came in and came up with the slogan-- do you think they believed that as well, or do you think they--
戴尔，你认为从华盛顿过来并提出这个口号的人——你认为他们也相信这一点吗，还是你认为他们——
No, I think that they knew that it might be misconstrued.
不，我认为他们知道这可能会被曲解。
The slogan set a tone for the campaign-- the very tone Epton said he didn't want. Now, it was going to be whites versus blacks, with Epton as the white savior. And soon, anonymous leaflets popped up in white neighborhoods all over the city. One of them read, "Your vote for Mr. Epton will stop contamination of the city hall by a Mr. Baboon." Around town, Epton supporters donned various buttons. One depicted a watermelon with a slash through it. Another button had nothing on it at all. It was just white. None of these were being distributed by Upton's campaign, but it was all being done in his name.
这个口号为竞选定下了一个基调——埃普顿说他不想的那种基调。现在，将是白人对阵黑人，埃普顿是白人救世主。很快，匿名传单出现在全市各地的白人社区。其中一张写着，“你投票给埃普顿先生将阻止‘狒狒先生’污染市政厅。”在城里，埃普顿的支持者戴着各种徽章。一个描绘了一个画了斜线的西瓜。另一个徽章上什么都没有。它只是白色的。这些都不是埃普顿的竞选团队分发的，但这都是以他的名义完成的。
One day, my mom and my father and I were walking somewhere. And I remember someone coming up and saying to me, "I'm going to vote for your father because he's white." And I said, "Don't bother. Please, we don't want your vote." And my mom said, "Dale, you just have to realize that some people feel this way." I never saw my father recoil from-- I never saw him show any issues with getting support for the wrong reasons, unlike myself. He had been in politics a long time and he was willing to accept a vote for a vote.
有一天，我妈妈、我父亲和我走在某处。我记得有人走过来对我说，“我要投票给你父亲，因为他是白人。”我说，“别费心了。拜托，我们不需要你的选票。”我妈妈说，“戴尔，你必须意识到有些人有这种感觉。”我从未见过我父亲退缩——我从未见过他表现出对因为错误原因获得支持有任何问题，不像我自己。他从政很久了，他愿意接受每一张选票。
Thank you. Thank you all so much. We have some other meetings to go to. Believe me, I'd much rather stay here with you. I don't think there's any meeting that can compete with you. I've found a fountain of youth. Being with you, your enthusiasm--
谢谢。非常感谢你们。我们还有其他会议要参加。相信我，我宁愿和你们待在这里。我不认为有什么会议能比得上你们。我找到了青春之泉。和你们在一起，你们的热情——
The rallies energized Epton. In just a few weeks, he'd gone from being a pretty obscure but principled state legislator to a man who was now drawing crowds of 10,000.
集会激发了埃普顿。在短短几周内，他从一个相当默默无闻但有原则的州立法者变成了现在吸引1万人参加集会的人。
Bernie, you look tired.
伯尼，你看起来很累。
Actually, I love it. I don't often get this kind of exposure. It's really a pleasure.
其实，我喜欢它。我不经常获得这种曝光。这真是一种荣幸。
Are you having a good time?
你玩得开心吗？
Much better than I  expected, especially now.
比我预期的要好得多，尤其是现在。
And most places he went, hordes of people chanted his name-- Bernie, Bernie, Bernie.
而且他去的大多数地方，大批人高呼他的名字——伯尼，伯尼，伯尼。
It was uncomfortable. It was uncomfortable for a whole bunch of people.
那让人不舒服。这对很多人来说都不舒服。
Don Siegel was one of Epton's law partners.
唐·西格尔是埃普顿的法律合伙人之一。
It was always interesting to me when I would watch on television and he would if he would go out to the Southwest Side where the Republican votes were-- and certainly the anti-Washington votes. And it was Bernie, Bernie, Bernie. And I remember thinking, nobody calls him Bernie unless you really knew him well. And yet, here are these strangers, with whom he would probably not want to sit down and have a cup of coffee because they were so different from him politically and emotionally and every other way, now saying Bernie, Bernie, Bernie. But that was not him.
当我观看电视时，他总是让我觉得很有趣，如果他去了共和党选票所在的中西部——当然还有反华盛顿的选票。那是伯尼，伯尼，伯尼。我记得我当时想，没有人叫他伯尼，除非你真的非常了解他。然而，在这里，这些陌生人，他可能不想和他们坐下来喝杯咖啡，因为他们在政治上、情感上和各方面都与他截然不同，现在却喊着伯尼，伯尼，伯尼。但那不是他。
Ladies and gentlemen, the next mayor of the city of Chicago, Bernie Epton.
女士们先生们，芝加哥市下一任市长，伯尼·埃普顿。
When I started this campaign a long time ago, it was, Bernie who? Today, I have an identity and that I owe entirely to all of you.
当我很久以前开始这次竞选时，那是，“伯尼是谁？”今天，我有了一个身份，这完全归功于你们所有人。
Very quickly, Epton's candidacy sparked a mass defection from the Democratic party. It was unprecedented. Some of the most prominent white Democratic politicians in the city-- these longtime party hacks-- in a town where party loyalty was everything, were now turning their back on their own mayoral candidate because he happened to be black. And Epton got caught up in that fervor and the possibility of winning. It was blinding.
很快，埃普顿的候选资格引发了民主党的大规模叛逃。这是前所未有的。一些城市中最著名的白人民主党政治家——这些长期的政党黑客——在一个政党忠诚高于一切的城镇，现在因为他们的市长候选人碰巧是黑人而背弃了他。埃普顿陷入了那种狂热和获胜的可能性中。那是盲目的。
But one of Epton's campaign workers-- his policy director, Haskel Levy, began having qualms. He'd already confronted Epton over the slogan and Epton, even while defending the slogan, told him, "Haskel, stay with me. If we win this election, I'll get rid of all these Republican operatives and opportunistic Democrats and we'll do good work once we get in." And so Haskel stayed. But then, one afternoon at campaign headquarters, Haskel noticed a pile of papers by the front door. They were hundreds of copies of an op-ed piece written by William Safire, conservative columnist for the New York Times .
但埃普顿的竞选工作人员之一——他的政策总监哈斯克尔·利维开始产生疑虑。他已经就口号问题与埃普顿对峙过，埃普顿即使在为口号辩护时也告诉他，“哈斯克尔，和我待在一起。如果我们赢了这次选举，我会摆脱所有这些共和党操作人员和机会主义民主党人，一旦我们进入，我们就会做很好的工作。”所以哈斯克尔留下了。但后来，一天下午在竞选总部，哈斯克尔注意到前门边有一堆文件。它们是数百份《纽约时报》保守派专栏作家威廉·萨菲尔撰写的观点文章。
It basically claimed the following-- if blacks can vote for blacks because they're blacks, whites can vote for whites because they're whites. And I looked at it and I just hit the roof. And I took the whole pile and threw it into the garbage can. It's a shallow-- it's a stupid way of looking at the world. It's just false.
它基本上声称以下内容——如果黑人因为是黑人而可以投票给黑人，白人就可以因为是白人而投票给白人。我看着它，直接炸了。我拿起了整堆东西，扔进了垃圾桶。这是一种肤浅的——一种愚蠢的看待世界的方式。这只是错误的。
Right, but also, it was in the context of what had been going on in that campaign. In some ways, the campaign was using it to justify--
对，但也，它是在那次竞选中发生的事情背景下。在某种程度上，竞选活动利用它来证明——
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] incendiary-- an incendiary thing. It was being passed out-- people were coming in to collect them to give out in the neighborhoods. When blacks get screwed because they're blacks, they're a legitimate interest group. What is the white interest group? I can understand a Pole voting for a Pole, a Czech voting for a Czech, but why would a white vote for another white? The only thing, in this particular circumstance, they have in common is that they don't like blacks.
[听不清] 煽动性的——一件煽动性的事情。它正在被分发——人们进来收集它们在社区里分发。当黑人因为是黑人而被欺负时，他们是一个合法的利益集团。什么是白人利益集团？我可以理解一个波兰人投票给波兰人，一个捷克人投票给捷克人，但为什么白人要投票给另一个白人？在这一特定情况下，他们唯一共同点是他们不喜欢黑人。
And so it was after that that you went and talked to Bernie Epton the second time.
所以在那之后，你第二次去找伯尼·埃普顿谈话。
This was the second time and I said that I'd had it. I said, do you realize what's happening? I said, you have to repudiate the racist campaign. You've got to repudiate any people that are supporting out of racist reasons. And if you don't, I'm gone. And if you don't, I'm voting for Harold Washington. And Bernie said his argument is correct-- Safire's argument is correct. And I said, that's it Bernie. And that's when he got pissed off. And he picked up my coat and jacket and briefcase and he ostentatiously threw it out of his office. And he literally said, get that [BLEEP] out. And he threw me out of the office. And I left. That was the end of it.
这是第二次，我说我受够了。我说，你意识到发生了什么吗？我说，你必须抵制种族主义竞选。你必须抵制任何出于种族主义原因支持的人。如果你不这样做，我就走了。如果你不这样做，我就投票给哈罗德·华盛顿。伯尼说他的论点是正确的——萨菲尔的论点是正确的。我说，够了伯尼。那时他生气了。他拿起我的外套、夹克和公文包，大摇大摆地把它们扔出了他的办公室。他真的说，把那[哔]拿出去。他把我赶出了办公室。我离开了。那是结局。
Washington and Epton had served together in the state legislature and they knew each other well. In fact, during the campaign, Washington at one point told a friend, that's not Bernie. That's not the Bernie I know.
华盛顿和埃普顿曾在州立法机构一起任职，他们非常了解彼此。事实上，在竞选期间，华盛顿有一次告诉朋友，那不是伯尼。那不是我认识的伯尼。
Chicago's Democratic candidate for mayor, Harold Washington, and Democratic presidential front runner Walter Mondale, were run out of a white neighborhood in Chicago today.
芝加哥民主党市长候选人哈罗德·华盛顿和民主党总统初选领跑者沃尔特·蒙代尔今天被赶出了芝加哥的一个白人社区。
And then it happened, an incident so sour that the whole nation took notice. This is a report from NBC National News. It's Palm Sunday at Saint Pascal's church on the North Side, and the streets are lined with white people holding Epton for Mayor signs.
然后发生了，一个让全国都注意到的令人厌恶的事件。这是NBC国家新闻的报道。那是圣帕斯卡教堂的棕榈周日，北区，街道上排满了拿着“埃普顿市长”标语的白人。
The Washington-Mondale motorcade stopped a block short of the church. The two candidates walked the rest of the way through an angry crowd, encountering the most open racial hostility of this racially-tense campaign.
华盛顿-蒙代尔车队在离教堂一个街区的地方停了下来。两位候选人在愤怒的人群中步行走完剩下的路，遭遇了这场种族紧张竞选中最公开的种族敌意。
95% of the blacks vote for Washington. They are more racist than we are. Who the hell are they trying to kid?
95%的黑人投票给华盛顿。他们比我们更种族主义。他们想欺骗谁？
Within minutes, Washington decided to cancel this appearance.
几分钟内，华盛顿决定取消这次露面。
Someone had scrawled on the church in huge letters, "nigger die". Epton had to respond, and he did.
有人在教堂上用巨大的字迹写着“黑鬼去死”。埃普顿必须回应，他做到了。
I am appalled that any people in any community would interfere with the worship by any religious denomination. And like you, I reject any of that antagonism or racism or bias or call it what you will.
我感到震惊的是，任何社区的任何人在任何宗教派别中干扰礼拜。就像你们一样，我拒绝任何那种对抗或种族主义或偏见，或者随你怎么称呼它。
But the damage been done. The amazing, and perhaps frightening, thing about it is, Epton almost won. He lost the election by a mere 3% of the vote. It was frightening not because Epton might not have been a good mayor, but rather because it was clear that the only reason he might have won-- a relatively unknown Republican in an overwhelmingly Democratic city-- was because he was white.
但损害已经造成。令人惊奇，也许令人恐惧的是，埃普顿差点就赢了。他以仅仅3%的选票输掉了选举。这之所以令人恐惧，不是因为埃普顿可能不会成为一个好的市长，而是因为很明显，他可能获胜的唯一原因——在一个绝大多数为民主党的城市里一个相对默默无闻的共和党人——是因为他是白人。
And this is the moment, right after he lost, where Bernie Epton could have saved his reputation. He could have made a brave, difficult speech to try to heal a divided and bitter city-- a speech where he reminded everyone why they liked him in the first place, which is precisely what John McCain did in November. In his concession speech, McCain was generous, dignified, humble. He acknowledged this incredible moment in history and urged everyone to bridge their differences. He stepped outside of his own personal defeat at the moment when it must've been the hardest thing to do.
这是那一刻，就在他输了之后，伯尼·埃普顿本可以挽救他的名声。他本可以发表一个勇敢、艰难的演讲来试图治愈一个分裂和痛苦的城市——一个提醒每个人为什么他们起初喜欢他的演讲，这正是约翰·麦凯恩在11月所做的。在让步演讲中，麦凯恩慷慨、庄重、谦逊。他承认了这一历史性的时刻，并敦促每个人弥合他们的分歧。他在最困难的时候迈出了自己个人的失败。
Epton missed his moment, his moment to rise above it all, to congratulate the new mayor, to call for the city to come together, to reclaim himself.
埃普顿错过了他的时刻，他超越这一切的时刻，去祝贺新市长，呼吁城市团结起来，去重塑自己的时刻。
Early the next morning, the Wednesday after the Tuesday election--
第二天一大早，周二选举后的周三——
Don Siegel again, Epton's law partner.
再次是唐·西格尔，埃普顿的法律合伙人。
I received a call from someone very high up in the Washington campaign saying that they're going to have a unity breakfast and that it was going to be important for the city that everybody get together as quickly as possible to show that the city, in fact, is going to be relatively united and we're not going to have any major problems.
我接到华盛顿竞选团队中一位非常高层的人的电话，说他们要举行团结早餐会，并且对于城市来说，每个人尽快聚在一起以显示城市实际上将相对团结，我们不会有任何重大问题，这很重要。
And so he said, "I've been trying to reach Bernie." This was early in the morning, "and I haven't been able to reach him." And he said, "I assume, Don, you've got a number that you can reach him." And of course I did. Bernie's wife, Audrey answered. And I said, "can I talk to Bernie? And she said, "I don't think so, Don. We're leaving to Florida and we're just getting ready to leave."
所以他说，“我一直在试图联系伯尼。”这是清晨，“但我一直没能联系上他。”他说，“我想，唐，你有一个号码可以联系到他。”当然我有。伯尼的妻子奥黛丽接了电话。我说，“我能和伯尼说话吗？”她说，“我不这么认为，唐。我们要去佛罗里达，我们正准备离开。”
I said, "Well, this is important." And she said, "I don't think so." I said, "Well, could you just tell him that I'm on the phone and I got a call from the Washington office and they have a breakfast and they would want him to attend, of course." And she said, "Bernie, it's Don. There's a unity breakfast. You want to talk to him?" And then she came back and she said, "No, we're going to Florida. And that's it. I'm sorry, Don. I'm sure you understand." And that was it.
我说，“嗯，这很重要。”她说，“我不这么认为。”我说，“嗯，你能不能告诉他我在电话上，我接到了华盛顿办公室的电话，他们有早餐会，他们当然希望他出席。”她说，“伯尼，是唐。有团结早餐会。你想和他说话吗？”然后她回来，她说，“不，我们要去佛罗里达。就这样。抱歉，唐。我相信你理解。”就这样。
And there's no question in my mind he was just so devastated by those events--
毫无疑问，他只是被那些事件摧毁了——
But devastated by the fact that he lost or devastated by how the campaign--
但摧毁是因为他输了，还是摧毁因为竞选——
It was the culmination-- everything coming together-- when he woke up that morning and just realized, now I'm not mayor and-- and again, this is a little psychoanalytical-- and maybe just realizing, and maybe people are going to remember me for some of the wrong reasons. He's got a legacy that he wasn't going to be proud of. I think he just wanted to get away.
那是顶点——一切都在一起——当他那天早上醒来并意识到，现在我不是市长了——再一次，这有点心理分析——也许只是意识到，也许人们会因为一些错误的原因记住我。他有一个他不会引以为豪的遗产。我想他只是想离开。
Wanted to disappear.
想消失。
Absolutely.
绝对。
In that time after the election, in its wake, there was one person who was both close to Bernie Epton and yet had some perspective-- someone who still is trying to make sense of what happened to Epton, not just during the campaign but afterwards. And that's Epton's son, Jeff, who I had met years earlier. While his dad was running for mayor in Chicago as a Republican, Jeff was running for city council in Ann Arbor, Michigan, far to the left of his dad, as a Democratic Socialist. Their relationship had been strained for years, mainly over their political differences. I interviewed Jeff for NPR's Morning Edition in 1983, a week before his dad lost the election.
在选举后的那段时间里，余波中，有一个人既亲近伯尼·埃普顿，又有一些视角——一个仍然试图理解埃普顿身上发生了什么的人，不仅是在竞选期间，而且在事后。那是埃普顿的儿子杰夫，我几年前见过他。当他父亲在芝加哥竞选共和党市长时，杰夫正在密歇根州安阿伯竞选市议会，远在父亲左翼，作为民主社会主义者。他们的关系多年来一直很紧张，主要是因为他们的政治分歧。我在1983年，他父亲输掉选举前一周为NPR的《早间新闻》采访了杰夫。
It's a different question, but if you lived in Chicago, would you vote for your dad?
这是一个不同的问题，但如果你住在芝加哥，你会投你父亲吗？
I think that there's a line I have to draw here. My father's perhaps the man that I have the deepest love and respect for of anyone I know. There are, like I said, those political differences. How I would resolve the contradiction between those differences and my deep affection for him, I think, has to remain my private business.
我想我必须在这里划一条线。我父亲可能是我认识的人中，我怀有最深爱和尊重的人。正如我所说，那些政治分歧存在。我如何解决这些分歧与我对他深厚感情之间的矛盾，我想，这必须保持为我的私事。
When Bernie Epton, in the thick of his losing campaign, heard what his son said, he stopped talking to him. Then, several months after the election, Jeff got a phone call from his dad pretty much out of the blue. His dad said nothing about not having spoken in months and invited Jeff to a White Sox game in Chicago.
当伯尼·埃普顿在输掉竞选的阵痛中，听到他儿子所说的话时，他停止了与他说话。然后，选举几个月后，杰夫接到了他父亲莫名其妙的电话。他父亲什么也没说关于几个月没说话的事，邀请杰夫去芝加哥看白袜队比赛。
We go to Comiskey Park-- the old Comiskey-- and it's before the first pitch. The crowd's really pumped. When my dad walks into the stadium, he's an instantly recognizable guy. He's got all this celebrity from the campaign a few months earlier. He's completely familiar looking to people. And as we're walking to our seats, people start recognizing dad and they come up to him to shake his hand.
我们去了科米斯基公园——旧的科米斯基——那是第一球投出之前。人群真的很兴奋。当我父亲走进体育场时，他是一个一眼就能认出来的人。他有几个月前竞选的所有名气。他看起来对人们完全熟悉。当我们走到座位上时，人们开始认出爸爸，他们走过来和他握手。
And after a while, people start chanting Bernie, Bernie. Now, it's not the whole stadium, but it feels like a lot people. And the crowd's all white. There are certainly not black voters going Bernie, Bernie. And it suddenly starts feeling wrong to me. And I can feel the hair standing up on the back of my neck-- Bernie, Bernie, Bernie. And I'm thinking, they don't know you. They don't know who you were. They don't know what you stand for. And they love you for bad reasons.
过了一会儿，人们开始高呼伯尼，伯尼。现在，这不是整个体育场，但感觉像是很多人。人群都是白人。当然没有黑人选民喊伯尼，伯尼。这突然让我觉得不对劲。我能感觉到我脖子后面汗毛直竖——伯尼，伯尼，伯尼。我在想，他们不认识你。他们不知道你是谁。他们不知道你代表什么。他们因为错误的原因爱你。
Those bad reasons being?
那些错误的原因是？
Because you represented us in the fight to save Chicago before it was too late. But it's also, you can see the power, the transforming effect it has on my father. He is so happy and this is washing over him. He is just delighted and smiling and waving and talking to people and standing a little straighter and just energized.
因为你代表我们在为时未晚之前拯救芝加哥的战斗中。但这也是，你能看到它对我父亲产生的力量，转变效应。他太高兴了，这正洗刷着他。他只是很高兴，笑着挥手，和人们说话，站得直了一些，充满活力。
That small moment of euphoria didn't last. Strangers at baseball games cheered Epton, but he became an outsider in his own city. He lost friends, his law firm began to collapse. He became more and more withdrawn he didn't even talk with anyone about the campaign, not his daughter Dale or his son Jeff. On those few occasions after the election when he gave an interview or spoke publicly, Epton blamed the media for getting him wrong.
那短暂的欣快感并没有持续。棒球比赛上的陌生人为埃普顿欢呼，但他成了自己城市里的局外人。他失去了朋友，他的律师事务所开始崩溃。他变得越来越退缩，他甚至不和任何人谈论竞选，不是他的女儿戴尔，也不是他的儿子杰夫。选举后他接受采访或公开发言的少数几次，埃普顿责怪媒体误解了他。
He always felt abused by the process himself. He could never separate his sense of being a victim from the feeling that he had a responsibility there, as well, that he might have failed.
他自己总是感到被过程滥用了。他永远无法将自己作为受害者的感觉与他也有责任、他可能失败了的感觉分开。
And then, in 1987, there was the final blow. Bernie Epton had heard that Harold Washington was thinking of appointing him to a commission. But the day before Thanksgiving, Washington died of a heart attack. And the way Jeff sees it, his dad, who had battled depression in the past, lost what he saw as his last chance of any kind of public redemption.
然后，在1987年，出现了最后一击。伯尼·埃普顿听说哈罗德·华盛顿正在考虑任命他进入一个委员会。但在感恩节前一天，华盛顿死于心脏病发作。在杰夫看来，他父亲，过去曾与抑郁症作斗争，失去了他认为的任何形式的公众救赎的最后机会。
Three weeks later, Epton went to Ann Arbor to visit Jeff.
三周后，埃普顿去了安阿伯探望杰夫。
I went out with him the night before he died. And it was clear he didn't want to live anymore. We had been intending to go out to dinner and go to a movie. We ended up going to McDonald's and he didn't eat and then he asked to be taken home-- not home, the hotel he was staying in. He was broke. His reputation was in tatters. He was in bad shape, and he died that night. People suggested that it was probably heart failure. I have my own thoughts about how things proceeded.
在他去世的前一天晚上，我出去了。很明显他不想再活下去了。我们本打算去吃饭，去看电影。我们最后去了麦当劳，他没吃，然后他要求被带回家——不是家，他住的旅馆。他破产了。他的名声一团糟。他状况很糟，那天晚上他去世了。人们建议那可能是心脏衰竭。关于事情如何进行，我有我自己的想法。
Jeff didn't want to say any more about that. The very first sentence of Bernie Epton's obituary in The New York Times describes him as the man who came close to wrecking Harold Washington's 1983 effort to become the first black mayor of Chicago. It would be glib to say that Epton couldn't escape that characterization. Maybe he could have. It's what Jeff hopes, that maybe, somehow, he still can.
杰夫不想再多说了。伯尼·埃普顿在《纽约时报》讣告中的第一句话形容他是那个差点破坏哈罗德·华盛顿1983年努力成为芝加哥第一位黑人市长的人。说埃普顿无法逃脱这种描述会很轻率。也许他本可以的。这就是杰夫所希望的，也许，以某种方式，他仍然可以。
Alex Kotlowitz it is the author of many books, including Never a City So Real, which is about Chicago.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨是许多书的作者，包括《从不如此真实的城市》，那是关于芝加哥的。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and me with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from [? Andi Dixon. ?] Seth Lind's our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper. [ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS] Our website-- www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. I've actually got him on the line. Torey, why don't you say a few words about your difficult, difficult job?
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我与亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、萨拉·科尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同制作。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。来自[？安迪·迪克森？]的制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。来自杰西卡·霍珀的音乐帮助。[鸣谢] 我们的网站——www.thisamericanlife.org。此美国生活由国际公共广播电台分发。WBEZ管理层对我们的节目由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生进行监督。我实际上让他在线上。托里，你为什么不说几句关于你困难、困难的工作的话呢？
I never talk about work when I'm not working. I make an exception for you, though.
我不在工作时从来不谈论工作。不过为你我破例一次。
Thanks, Torey. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
谢谢，托里。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到更多这种美国生活的故事。